okay let's try this this is the Levinsky
attack and now what well I'm gonna chop
that night up there hmm okay so with
this compromised pawn structure what
should I be doing how should I be
reacting to this my pawns ideally we are
going to be on dark squares so let's do
this as a start I don't know what I want
to do it okay wait a second now that
Bishop already declared its intentions I
would love to get a night on h5 so let's
shoot for there's a couple different
ways I can get there okay I think I have
can i go so far as to say a wedding
strategy maybe I might have a winning
strategy here to throw my opponent in a
very difficult position
so what's the plan here if i play my
knight here that's got to be real
annoying
if I push my pawn hmm I'm trying to do
I'm thinking of something like h4 and
forcing this pond to move and only then
challenging the bishop see if I
challenge the bishop right now there's
no worry for black they could say okay
so what you capture my bishop I
recaptured my H pond and then the rook
comes to life
however after h4 and age something if I
play here it's a different story because
the H pond isn't around to defend the
bishop Knight here's another thought I
think I'm actually liking that or am i
no after night here there's bishop here
let's try this
threatening to trap the bishop h5 the
bishop is clearly running out of squares
now if h6 is played then what then I'll
think a bit more about night five
because then there isn't a Bishop h6
move
if h5 is played then I think I can be
considering Bishop here and I think this
is a good start right here right now
with the follow up being Bishop to d3 I
want to stick around on the h5 square I
think it's a wonderful square Bishop
takes Knight my Queens just recaptures
and is in a great spot
whoa now that is something that I did
not expect how could I take advantage of
that
is there any way Bishop here I'm really
liking my knight much better than that
Bishop rook up and over as an idea but I
think in order to make progress I need
to crack at that light square bishop if
there is this capture I will definitely
consider pond takes two reasons one
half-open see file form I reckon to the
Queen could play to g4 in one shot which
would be leading to mate actually so
it's a very serious threat Bishop takes
pawn takes half open file and a mate in
two threat right here right out of the
gates so now what what do you do if
you're not familiar with this well you
really do need to be familiar with this
structure against this Bishop g5 move
and I think it's something I should be
looking into I say that from time to
time about how certain openings I should
be learning more about because I think
it would fit well with my opening
repertoire this being one of them and I
think if I play my queen out right here
there is a four and the door gets
slammed on my bishop queen g4 pawn push
I think I'd be okay with that or what
about night takes and then pond push
let's see if I play queen g4 pawn push
Bishop back to I think home it's home
square and that way I have a knight f4
move coming up I'm gonna try that I
think this is working and I think it's
very important to know how to react to
this e4 move they seem awkward but I
think it's a necessity if after efore if
I played here my queen doesn't have I
just miscalculated no I didn't know I
didn't know I didn't I didn't I did this
bishop most of my queen he could come
back to one of these two squares and
defend my knight I was thinking after
this I had to play here I'm off with
that though let's do this I want to
support that pawn and I think I want to
get in Knight f4 real soon this is
starting to be very scary very very
scary I didn't want to have to capture
like that but I think I'm needing to
this is very very scary okay so now I
need to get developed this is not good
and I'm not moving quick enough yeah I
need I need to go click here pawn push
this is not good I did not want to have
to take like this now this pond has
possibilities of pushing forward and the
position can open up real soon I am NOT
castled and I am also constrained in
some way my queen having to watch over
the knight I think I'm lost I think
there's a wonderful continuation here I
don't want to share it though
I share it is my opponent gonna see it
might they be listening in are you
listening
well you are playing against me if you
are shame on you
okay now what okay I get this pun
I thought the continuation was this f5
move followed by Bishop takes pawn which
is having that Knight came out there I
could get this guy I'm gonna take them I
don't want to take the light square
Bishop because then there's mate threat
on f2 within forking range e 7 and F 6
both are covered by the dark square
Bishop I'm just ready to come back here
though maybe push this light square
Bishop around a little bit so there was
something that definitely went wrong I'm
I and I'm weaseling out of it hopefully
I could still convert this I am on the
Queen that is the first thing black
needs to be dealing with and now the
knight could be playing here or the
bishop coming out I'm gonna give check
and if the King plays here the bishop
I'll probably kick it away with this
move actually let's still just do it and
I think the bishop has to go probably
here okay I want to maintain my Knights
position this is scary I'm gonna allow
for Bishop takes pawn I'm not gonna
recapture if that occurs my Queen out if
Bishop takes here I'm not going to
recapture and let me defend here 22
seconds this pawn is falling but I'm ok
with giving something back just to get
the Queens off let's do this actually
let's get more material off here and in
this endgame I think everything is going
to be alright I think and a weasel my
night around a little bit here I get a
Bishop off the board maybe okay off the
board and let's get up quickly and get
that Bishop and then get here I was
gonna play here right away but get that
pun I get this pawn they're pushing
though they're going quick what's the
trick pawn push they're gonna take that
right here push push push then grab this
guy and push push push again get another
Queen this is a lot of time okay
in a position where you can make those
kind of pre moves four seconds is a lot
good game down to the wire and I should
not have weaseled out like I did I think
those moves that were played with the c5
and opening it up on the Queen side
we're very good I think your queen
coming out earlier would have placed me
in a very difficult spot so let's have a
closer look with this structure what do
you want to do you're gonna want to take
into account okay I'm ready chop your
bishop I think I stand better here I
didn't do well with taking advantage of
this compromise King side structure but
there's just something definitely is
crying out to me like there's gotta be
something here with me but maybe Knight
f4 I'm seeing this as a possibility now
Knight f4 threatening a knight for
Bishop exchange and if you back up then
maybe challenge the bishop and then get
my knight back to this square and my
queen out to g4 so there's got to be
something here for white I did not do
things well
so actually before it even gets to that
point I would consider right now not
developing the dark square bishop you
could look into just Bishop well it's
still maybe a bit a bit annoying right
there Bishop f5 because of this Knight
maneuver again I think I think this
should be alright though how about
Bishop f5 if I go with the 92 you play
h5 and if Knight G you back up my
there's still some calculation either
because I guess there is the possibility
for white if black is going to be
playing this h5 move where the knight
Bishop and Queen could eventually
converge on that h5 point what else
let's see ya the bishop move I don't
know if that's right cuz maybe you want
to come out to d6 or something's maybe
getting in Bishop here and then II six
I'm not sure I know at this point I am
the tables turned like right here boom
with this structural change and then c5
that's a good move c3 takes takes
instead of the knight move I think you
give me a little bit of time to wheeze a
lot of things and I think instead of the
knight move how about Queen to b6 what
do I do if you play Queen b6 I guess
what one thing I am threatening and I'm
just seeing it now his knight takes
Bishop did I have this for a while and I
was just missing it Knight takes Bishop
followed by a pawn push that I was
actually totally blind to that for the
whole game if that was available after
pawn push right now it's available seen
that right now Knight takes bishop pawn
push was available to me okay
well anyhow at this point right here
well I guess it's still available but
now it's a little bit scarier cuz that
pond can kind of go crazy yeah this is
tough even right now it's available yeah
talk about a blind spot it's one of
those if you don't see it you just don't
see it I wasn't seeing it wow that's a
simple tactic - oh well yeah Knight
takes pawn push but anyhow right here I
was thinking the Queen should be coming
out right now to be disruptive to my
Queen side but I guess there's a bigger
concerns maybe this is playable right
now if Knight takes bishop there's Queen
takes pawn I don't know how to run all
the calculations accurately with that
but yeah you're having to do something
and right now I think you're standing
better
I'm gonna take the night and then push
the pot or something this is this is
very tough I don't like having my queen
tied down to the night but anyhow my
earliest suggestion seen a lot of things
missed on my end the same move missed
multiple times but don't declare that
darker bishops intentions so quick maybe
work on getting your LightScribe Bishop
out and then playing e6 and at least
reserve the option of the bishop
deploying itself in either direction